if we're gonna get out of here we're
gonna need to get into that launch Tower
and to do that I'm gonna need a few
things
the guards wear security bands to
control their ins and outs I need one
leave it to me that dude there I need
his prosthetic leg his leg Yeah
I know they don't need the rest of them
look at them he's useless
all right and finally on the wall back
there is a black panel Blinky yellow
light you see it yeah there's a quandex
battery behind it purplish box green
wires to get into that Watchtower I
definitely need it how are we supposed
to do that well supposedly these ball
bodies find you attractive so maybe you
can work out some sort of trade you must
be joking no I really heard they find
you attractive look it's 20 feet up in
the air and it's in the middle of the
most heavily guarded part of the prison
it's impossible to get up there without
being seen I got one planted that plan
requires a freaking quantix battery so
figure it out
can I get back to it thanks now this is
important once the battery is removed
everything is going to slam into
emergency mode once we have it we gotta
move quickly so you definitely need to
get that last
or we could just get it first and
improvise I'll get the armband
[Music]
prisoner drop the device immediately and
Retreat to your cell or we will open
fire
oh yeah
[Music]
right
all prisoners return in your sleeping
areas
[Music]
you idiot how am I supposed to fight
these things without my stops
[Music]
plenty little beast oh
you need my what